did you know that earth hour is actually  a terrible idea  yeah during earth hour people use  candles for light  this isn't the best idea as not only are  they 100 times less efficient than your  light bulb but they also emit carbon  dioxide if you lit up twice as many  candles to make up for one light bulb  you'd actually be emitting more carbon  dioxide coal burning plants would emit  less carbon dioxide during this hour but  after that everyone would turn their  lights back on for power stations this  sudden increase in demand means firing  up more generators  as a result they emit even more co2 and  this extra carbon waste starts to trap  more heat in our lower atmosphere  possibly speeding up climate change so